bon et maintenant qu'on a acheté une
belle boîte à cigares à papa qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire un ghetto oui oui
mais dis donc qu'est ce que c'est ça
bonjour bonjour qu'est ce que c'est ça
pour caen et paramilitaires
dont l'essai d'évrecy gaffe
vous savez ce qu'on va faire on va faire
une farce à peine alors une tare ces
normes on va vider tous les cigares de
la boîte et à la place de ça on va lui
mettre des cigares en chocolat d'accord
à l'avenir
béatrice je voudrais un peu d'eau s'il
te plaît mon chéri
dont nous bruno pendant ce temps on va
faire la pâte alors tu vois qu'il prend
une plaque de chocolat chocolat à cuire
tu sais de 250 grammes équivalent a
cassé en petits morceaux dans la
casserole
merci mon chéri tu y arrives à rajouter
toit depuis hier à soupe d'eau y a plein
dans la boxe troll pour une eau laisse
travailler béatrice tu veux quand même
c'est une championne
tiens tu sais ce que tu vas faire
regarde la tranche horaire des voix
comme ça et qui va remplir un
aulas l'a
un peu plus encore
c'est des petites cuillers ça voilà
c'est parfait ça
alors le chocolat font mais attristé
valeur remuer les chocolats
tu tiens ça comme un pinceau mon chéri
prend là là tout simplement comme ça et
remuez doucement doucement il va fondre
tous ces retards ça va très vite
c'est lors comment idée
presque fondu il est presque fondu bruno
dans le réfrigérateur il ya de la crème
fraîche veux-tu l'amener s'il te plaît
ainsi continué m
[Musique]
merci
ça y est
quand il est bien fondu or mais en très
vite maintenant tu me le dis
tu vois si jamais tu laisses des
morceaux
et bien quand ils vont vouloir faire les
cigares tout à l'heure les roulés vous
faire des trucs parce que c'est la même
patte seoul ap ap des truffes au
chocolat temps c'est que tu achètes
ou des cigares bien du pouvoir pas
parce que les morceaux de chocolat vont
rester dans tes mains
mais ça sera pas égale ça sera pas rond
tout s'est tu pourras pas faire une
chose
voilà il est fondu et les faux nez on la
verse
tu rajoutes béatrice s'il te plaît
à ce chocolat 4 cuillères à soupe de
crème fraîche
tiens mon chéri
es tu mélanges
au nom tu rajoutes 2 tasse
de sucre glace tu sais que la tasse est
inverse et que 16 heures fait 20
centilitres toujours 20 centilitres
bien pleine tu le mets dans le large
dominatrice
si
tu mets la seconde
et tu rajoutes le sucre vanillé
laquelle sa famille et moi je préfère le
rhône
je paie qu'un drone mais de beaucoup le
voir médéa triste que je préfère
c'est très animé sais c'est pas
malheureux d'entendre des choses
pareilles ans à sa carrière bon alors tu
remues bien alors là tu vois quand tu
auras bien mélanger le sucre vanillé ta
pâte pour faire tes cigare au chocolat
est prête mais tu peux pas rouler des
cigares comme ça il faut qu'elle
durcisse est papa alors on va la mettre
au réfrigérateur mais l'endroit le plus
froid pour une heure et puis bonne
humeur tu vas pas mal à ressortir elle
va être mais dur dur dur comme du bois
d'accord donc on est accueilli hier au
stade cuillère
et va l'apporter réfrigérateur
très bien et pendant ce temps là pendant
qu'on va on va préparer nous les bagues
de cigare parce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
des bas comme ici je crois que les
cigarettes gens des îles ont des vrais
potes comme ça alors on va s'amuser à
dessiner des vrais dingues pour les
maîtres cigares en chocolat pour que ça
ait vraiment vraiment les visions de
cigares d'accord à dernière
ben c'est très beau c'est très vous
voyez regardez regardez aussi la patte
également
la casse et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec ça on va
la prendre comme de la pâte à modeler
avec des mains très propre ça tu vois
et puis on va faire on va modeler des
cigares énorme cigare
puis on va les passer dans
du chocolat en poudre
pas c'est vrai chocolat en cours
voilà
comme ça
et vite on va les mettre dans la boîte
sur le cigare moi je peux plus mais je
pense que tu peux toi tu vas enroulé une
balle comme ça
alors on est une
belle base des cigares
à la colère et la colère ça tout à faire
et on va continuer continuer continuer
pour faire tout à moi d'essayer
allez vas-y boulot
comme de la pâte à modeler
ça y est la place pourra encore oui je
pense pas un nanti en va on va le donner
un bruit non quand même évité le
partagera avec les monsieur bruno voulez
vous filmer ce cigare cantine
voulez-vous du feu
voilà il est vrai
assez pour moi tout
[Musique]